people of cervantes sight will return
i think people will be blown away when
they see what season two looks like
we are chosen to usher in a new world
the level of ambition on this show was
through the roof if i did not return
that i am dead
season 2 picks up about 30 days after
season 1 has ended and we rejoined baba
boss on his way to trovantes to rescue
his daughter
bob's going to face his past and
everything that he ran from and
everything that kind of made him
the mighty papavas
greetings brother
it's such a dark history baba killed
their father and disappeared idol hated
him for many years because of their
shared history and when he gets wind of
baba boss being around again he's going
to do everything in his power to destroy
his brother
there is danger peculiarities pop up
as the season continues we see a tension
build between everyone the cracks that
we're already starting to show
throughout season one just start
widening
i think you failed to realize just how
close to the edge we are
we're gonna go into this world that
we've never gotta experience in season
one
it's like he's crawling back into hell
this season is
the best season i've ever had
most men choose to avoid my father at
any
cost the general is not like most men
he's been waiting a very long time to
get his hands on top of us
[Applause]
home bubba
[Music]
you